I'm not naturally sort of a leader
leader but if I see you're doing
something good and I know I can benefit
from it I'll go and adapt and I'll apply
that but I think the basic ones
especially from a recruiting perspective
is lead by example I wouldn't be saying
anything to my guys something that I
wouldn't do or they can't do so I'll
have that in mind so leading leading
with an example also what I'm thinking
what I'm wanting from the team like
communicating that enough and make it
visible so that we're all bought into
the same vision if I've got a Target in
my head that I need to make a million
pound profit this year let's say and I'm
not communicating that to my top leaders
when I'm driving them because they don't
know they're not bought into it so I'm
just constantly telling them like well
Aaron this month this is a plan wait
this will be doing this is what it means
for you this one means for me how do we
get the troops behind it so I think
those two things leading by an example
having the vision and I think you had
Andrew on your show still a toast or
pick this up from him the framework the
management framework okay there's a
problem how do we solve it what options
do we've got so keeping it relevant
keeping it fresh and revisiting it
that's for me a leadership style that
works and the reality of the situation
is when you're working with like-minded
people when you're working with the kind
of people that you've either trained
yourself or you've got them into the
business yourself that does work because
they're more or less thinking like you
as well
foreign